Freddie answer so I hate you obviously
breaks my heart and it deserves to be on
the agenda here in Davos but in many
ways as an old story Haiti is less about
the the tragedy of this crisis a hundred
thousand almost 200,000 people their
lives lost a needless tragedy the same
crisis the same magnitude earthquake
they're about to hit San Francisco in
1989 hit Haiti but in San Francisco 68
people believe that's the number 68
people died certainly less than 100 in
Haiti almost 200,000 people have died
the problem with Haiti is poverty it's
not the nation's are any less
intelligent or any less ambitious is
that they are less able unless capable
to fend for themselves at the as a
result of that environment of poverty
you have poor infrastructure poor
government for government building poor
standards core values poor investments
and if you go back to when Haiti was an
economic leader for the colonies the
European colony several hundred years
ago they were doing really well until
they got into a war and beat Napoleon
the only country to to beat Napoleon
well some would say that as a result of
that some European interests made them
pay a price which was economic they're
still paying that price today we have a
chance to do it right to get it right
again to make sure this never happens to
Haiti again or any other place it's
vulnerable in the world by going in
after we've stabilized and after we help
people in this crisis let's not just
giving them sympathy let's give them
empathy let's give them a hand up and
not just a handout does not just be the
Good Samaritan along the Jericho Road
let's fix the Jericho Road let's go in
and and give them roads in gutters in
streetlights let's give them safe
environments let's give them an
opportunity for home ownership in
individual property rights and small
business ownership and entrepreneurship
and self-employment projects because
there's not enough jobs to go around and
corporations we know in Haiti are not
going to say
government largesse can't and shouldn't
save them we should give people the
dignity of being able to do for
themselves so I think that we should
really look at Mickey free enterprise
and capitalism work for the poor in 80
over the next two to ten years it should
be a massive serious campaign to empower
the Haitian people with dignity that's
ubud to i am me because you are you i
know president clinton the UN envoy is
doing his part i know there's certain
committees made here but you're the
first to hear that operation hope the
organization i founded that served more
than a million one hundred thousand
people will be going into haiti with a
massive five-year campaign to make free
enterprise and capitals and work for the
core to teach a generation of young
people financial literacy and remind
whadja money and given the dignity and
the ability to do for themselves